hey Seto files welcome to another monday
morning review i'm jay s and i'm shelly
and today we're talking about the latest
film from wes anderson at the grand
budapest hotel so Shelley right out of
the gate what did you think about this
film and how do you feel it fits in Wes
Anderson's entire body of work the grand
Budapest hotel is definitely one of my
favorites it was my top three Wow um
even though the pacing was pretty fast I
thought it was pretty modern and
contemporary and it was so so much fun
to watch it was like an adventure yeah
no I I see what you're saying about the
pacing this film is like a lightning
strike like there is so much happening I
mean it starts off slowly enough it
eases into this story I felt like a
roller coaster like there's so many
little chicks going on yeah I was just
looking at this I was in complete awe
i'm just all the sets I think the
production design of this movie is
incredible i believe it was stockhausen
who's worked with Wes Anderson before
yeah I feel like Wes Anderson has come
to a point in his career where he can
kind of build like a Disneyland like an
amusement park of all his worlds that
he's created yeah oh man that would be
amazing right yeah so yeah just looking
at his entire body work it's so
interesting to see how far he's come and
I I do feel this is his most epic
achievement today
it's staggering and just how much they
were able to put on screen you've seen
it twice right yes I mean did you pick
up on a lot more of the details yes time
around it was a lot more fun the first
time for me okay but the second time was
obviously a lot of fun too I also liked
the acting his out now um he didn't have
any breaks while he was filming to keep
the tension and suspense in the air the
whole time I feel like his style is so
clear and he underlines each character
so well that it's not hard to follow
yeah I can see that as well like it for
everything that is going on it is
remarkably comprehensive yeah and
because the characters and their
costumes and their quirks their
idiosyncrasies are also distinct we're
able to definitely differentiate between
all the pieces yeah I'm like no
character fell out of place or
extraneous there's an amazing chase
scene through a museum and Willem
Dafoe's character is chasing Jeff
Goldblum and you know it's just really
intense there's a lot of like just this
film noir German excuse i'm going on
with the shadows and everything and then
it just leads up into this really like
oh like there's moments of like extreme
violence and this movie that you don't
really get and a lot of wes anderson and
so yeah those moments are a little
shocking but also refreshing you get the
sense that wes anderson loves the
process of storytelling and how it can
you know it can change along the way and
with each of those changes i believe it
also changes an aspect ratio mm-hmm i'm
not mistaken so oh and one last note the
score by alexandre desplat is that task
he's my favorite contemporary composer
everything he does is remarkably
different and this is no exception yeah
all right well thanks for watching
another monday morning review for movie
clips i'm jay s and i'm shelly thicker
you
Oh